[Musique]
la seule chose dont je suis sûr, c'est qu'à
7 et 17 minutes du samedi
matin, elle a envoyé un SMS sur
WhatsApp à l'une des personnes qui sont
également allées à la fête et elle lui a écrit
qu'ils sont  tirez sur nous s'il vous plaît venez
nous sauver c'est tout ce que je
sais [Musique]
c'est tellement pathétique j'étais heureux d'apprendre
que mon bébé est dans le pire ennemi du
monde je veux dire Dieu sait ce qu'elle
traverse là-bas ce qu'ils
lui font I I I  Je ne peux même pas imaginer et
moi ce qu'ils lui font à mon
[Musique]
bébé
quoi [
Musique] [
Musique]
pour [
Je
[Musique]
elle est une vraie
survivante et je supplie le monde de
ramène mon bébé parce qu'elle est ma meilleure
amie, emmène-moi mais ramène mon bébé,
je te supplie de le ramener
vivant un jour
[Musique]
avant